- Can I get the water?
I don't, sorry. (chuckles)
I dunno where the water went.
All right, welcome. Look,
I know it's happy hour.
I know you have dinner plans
and I'm gonna just
start with that in mind,
and I will let you know the
whole reason I'm up here
is that I hope that you guys go back there
to Booth 435 and check
out Sonrai, thank you.
That's the agenda, right?
So, we have been partnered
with them this past year
and this presentation is
really about that partnership
and what we found valuable about that,
and hopefully you can do similar.
(people chattering)
Really, there's gonna
be four simple steps.
What was Fiserv's challenge?
Why were we looking for anything?
Number two, we're gonna talk
about tools a little bit,
and what can feel like when you're trying
to go through the process.
Then also the turning point.
What was it that we did with Sonrai
that actually made a difference
and why we then chose to
actually move forward?
And then of course the results.
(people chattering)
So, Fiserv is a financial
services company.
We're global and we probably,
I think it's been said
that we touch every household
in the United States.
I don't know if that's
physically true or not,
but we have grown and we have merged,
and we still continue to buy
companies and merge companies.
And that has led to over a period of years
where we are now multi-cloud.
We have thousands of accounts.
We have to manage those globally as well.
And so what happens is
every time you bring
another company together,
buy another product,
you have this permissions tornado,
for lack of a better word, right?
And IAM is difficult and we know
because when AI is all the hype,
And of course we work
in a regulated industry,
so you will always have to prove
that you have your cloud under control.
And so one of the things that
we were trying to implement,
especially with the rise of AI,
'cause, you know, everybody wants to know,
"What are you doing about AI?
What are you doing about AI?"
So, we had actually tried
to implement some controls
and we didn't fully,
well, we made an assumption
about some SCP inheritance
then turned out it worked that way
and we actually took an outage.
And so this happened
like middle of last year,
right before AWS Reinforce.
And so it just happened to be at Reinforce
where I saw, I was swag hunting, right?
We all walk around, we look for swag
and in that process I ran across Sonrai.
There's some thing there
called a Zombie Hunter
and I was attracted to that.
And so, you know, walk up,
and we do some small talk,
we exchange what are you doing here?
And but in that process
they said we automate
creation and deployment of SCPs.
At that point, I forgot about the T-shirt
that I was hunting for.
I forgot about the sticker.
We exchanged numbers,
we had a second date,
we did a POC with them
and that went great.
There was a few cloud formation templates.
I think it was like 30 minutes to set up,
Ryan, my partner who set that up.
And it took several
days to do the analysis,
and when we saw the numbers,
which we'll show you
more of this in a bit,
it was like, hey wait,
there's more to this than
just our immediate need.
So, we said, "Let's see about buying it.
Like let's continue this relationship."
(people chattering)
And then this is what happened.
Now, I'll tell you right up
front, this has nothing to do
with Sonrai, this was our processes,
but real questions.
Do we need another tool?
Why this tool?
Don't we already have
a tool that does that?
Who's gonna pay for it even
after we get it up and running?
Who's gonna operate
it? Is it a cyber tool?
Is it a cloud infrastructure
tool? Like what is it?
And so for us, the fact
that we did the POC,
and I would encourage you to do a POC,
is that we had our data
right there for us to see.
And it was easy to do demos
with other partners in our business
and in particular leadership.
And when we did work out the fact
that Sonrai offered something
that we didn't have in any
other tool in any other way,
and it was even more than
that, we decided to go ahead.
And the reason I brought all of that up
is because this is what
it feels like sometimes
when everything's going on.
One more meeting. One more question.
Do we do it again? (chuckles)
It's worth it, if the solution,
if any solution here, if it
fixes your need, it's worth it.
And that to me is why we did that.
All right, one second.
So, this is where I'm gonna
spend most of this time.
I'm actually gonna explain this.
(people chattering)
(Brent drinking water)
Sorry about that.
And I'm only gonna explain
enough for you to be interested
to go to Booth 435.
Remember my agenda.
So, at the top, what
you'll see is the scope,
in the little dropdown at the top.
You can do that at the root org,
any of your OUs,
or you can go down to individual accounts.
And by the way, these are not our numbers.
This is a stock photo.
Whatever scope you pick,
those numbers will change
to reflect what's based on that scope.
So, what is this?
These are hero cards I assume
because you're a hero if
you take action on those.
The first one is, IAM users
and roles with excessive permissions.
So, the easiest way to say this,
this is where we show you all the policies
that were probably written
with a wild card, right?
They're over permission,
but in particular they're not in use.
So, they're being flagged not
just being over permissive,
they're just not being used.
And you can take action
by clicking on that button
and it'll stage some
stuff, it'll do some stuff.
I'm not gonna tell you all
the stuff that it does,
that's these guys' job.
But what it does is it
prevents them from being used.
And if they try to use them,
it'll set off an alert so to speak.
And there's a workflow then
that you can take to give people
that permission to use
those if they need to.
But what it does is quickly gives you
that layer of control.
The second one, the whole reason
I was hunting those
stickers, the zombie hunters.
Zombies represent identities
which haven't been used.
It's not about the permission
just not being used, right?
It's junk in your accounts.
And again, much like this protection here,
you can quarantine the zombies
such that whenever somebody try,
like say it was a
quarterly thing that runs.
When that happens, again,
there's a workflow,
it'll get triggered.
Someone can then take action,
ask, okay, they can reach out
to that team, "Hey, I see
this alert, what is it?
Do you really need it?"
And there's, and again,
those action automation
and then also the workflow behind it.
Those were the things that
we didn't have in our system.
We don't, by the way, we
predate control tower,
we have our own control tower so to speak.
And this type of stuff
wasn't built into that,
at least not in this way.
The third one is the
one that is what we were
really looking for out of the gate, right?
We have new services, new
AI services coming out,
we're gonna leave here, there'll be more,
and you can use this
to turn them on or turn them off.
And so it was nice to
be able to see across
thousands and thousands
of counts just how much
we have in use, not in use.
And then we can drill down to any level.
So, anytime we're working
with one of our teams,
one of the app dev teams,
we can pull this up
and we can get just
another view of the data
that shows they have junk in there,
over permission stuff in there,
and do they need that service?
So, we use that now as part of the AI COE,
our Center of Excellence,
that when teams have an AI project,
they can come, they get approved
and this is how we turn those
services back on for them.
The third or the third parties
was actually not something
that was on there when
we first looked at it.
That was something they
were adding and that,
or it might have been the
regions, I forget now.
But anyway, the third party is,
the nice thing about that is
in a single place we can go
and we can look in any account
and we can see who's partnered with us.
A lot of it's, you know, hopefully
it's all okay. (chuckles)
But normally it's vendors, SaaS vendors,
people they have relationships
with like Snowflake
where you have database
connections and things like that.
But you can also from there drill down in
to see the policies.
And so that is something
again, to try to go see
all of that information
the natural way (chuckles)
through a query or whatever.
That's a lot more difficult.
Right here, just from this
console we can really drill down
and if we choose to take
action, you can block it.
So, that takes me then to the regions.
Regions is just like it says,
there's new regions.
AWS brings up good examples like India.
For a long time there's
only one region there.
In the banking you need two.
You know, for DR,
we've always struggled
with that other region.
So, when the regions
come on we can now say,
"Hey, this application, does
it actually need to be there?"
So, we can control that that way.
Down at the bottom you'll
see are the services.
So, if you click on wherever
you click on up there,
the numbers across the bottom are
from that service layer
will tell you how many
people are using it.
And you can also drill into
the sensitive permission.
So, this is a thing that
Sonrai has done for us,
which is they have people
all the time working the IAM.
That's a full-time job.
And that's just made it very easy for us.
We don't have to guess now and we take
their sensitive permissions
and you can choose to protect again.
So, the key to all of that
is when you take action in
the far corner up there,
you'll see the deploy button.
And then it'll take you
to see what is staged
and from there you can deploy it,
and I'll let them explain
exactly how that works.
(people chattering)
All right, I'm at 20 minutes.
So, let's just finish up here.
(people chattering)
Real quick though, I wanted to point out
the lines of code and the hours saved.
That essentially refers to the fact
that if our policies about
38, 40 lines of per SEP
and we have over a 1000 accounts,
that's lines of code that we
didn't have to copy and paste,
change the information and deploy.
And if I just calculated
an hour per account,
we've saved over a 1000 hours.
So, the numbers are probably
a lot more than that.
But it is a way for
you to look at getting,
how can this tool pay for itself, okay?
(people chattering)
All right, with that, I gotta
go 'cause I'm over the time.
But, (chuckles) thank you everyone.
I'll stick around, you can talk to me.
Sonrai guys are at Booth
435. I appreciate your time.
(audience applauding)